et pour en parler nous sommes avec vale
rang de saint-just trésorier du
rassemblement national et président du
groupe du conseil régional d'île de
france
bonsoir valérie st juste merci d'être un
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
vous avez été l'un des premiers à dire
que ce dessin de danièle obono avait été
maladroit mais votre parti aujourd'hui
dit aussi que cette indignation de la
france un soumises en général
s'apparente à de la victimisation
organisé il ya plusieurs choses dont on
peut critiquer à l'heure actuelle mais
moi j'ai critiqué en exemple des scènes
d'été de l'égout et qu'on ne
représentait pas une élue de la
république de sceptre à son vin texte 22
l'article tofas delà de la nouvelle est
aussi assez clair assez particulier
c'est une chose mais en faisant ça j'ai
pas du tout et chants du madame gonnot
puisque malavaud godeau est très
difficilement défendable et elle prend
un grand nombre de positions et qui sont
inacceptables et qui sont meilleurs et
qui chantait temps l'artiste de
valoriser cette en réaction à cela on
assiste à une américanisation des
esprits en france ou alors on a des
propos généraux est très critique et
très méprisant à l'égard des plumes en
général des noirs en général et à
l'extrême gauche
dans certains cercles de façon aussi
mais plus ample à l'égard des blancs en
france on s'est toujours fichu pour
rester poli totalement de la couleur de
pont des gens de deux de leurs origines
de la religion pour être français mais
ne pas être français
on se dit toujours ça nous ajoute
toujours été complètement égal et
spécialement au rassemblement national
de culture à s'angoisser de france avait
créé il n'a jamais fait attention à la
couleur de peau notamment à la couleur
de peau des bébés des gens et ça il faut
savoir il faut le répéter c'est ce que
j'ai voulu exprimer en critiquant le
dessin et l'article devenant actuel
alors parlé aussi dieu de l'article que
avait lui peut-être pas tout puisque
beaucoup commenté cette ce dessin le
journal a présenté ses excuses il se
défend politiquement de son caractère
raciste que la demande et lui prête j'ai
pas dis moi je n'ai pas dit il n'est pas
dit que le dessin ou marqué que terra
schiste je voudrais de redéfinir définir
de raciste avec beaucoup de précaution
et les réactions et ya des de madame
gonnot et de de tous ceux qui
l'entourent sont extraordinairement et
crécy est même totalement scandaleuse
j'ai peut-être entendu un peu lassant la
conversation elle dit que la france est
peuplé de racisme ça sachez que c'est
ignoble dans sa bouche c'est totalement
idiot c'est inacceptable de la part de
madame angot noé si je peux m'exprimer
je serai certainement encore plus cher
qu'à l'égard de valeurs actuelles
- en tant que responsable politique
c'est sa lutte il faut bien l'avouer ce
qu'est son coin finalement c'est que ce
soit une députée qui est caricaturé on a
vu cette semaine et le procès de
serviettes dos on peut caricaturer un
prophète mais pas une députée la
république il le député une femme qui a
la peau noire
dans les circonstances actuelles je
trouve écoutez moi je parle en tant que
responsable politique
valeurs actuelles le avoir aussi des
responsabilités poli et bien nous avons
des responsabilités justement tout court
et nous devons oeuvrer pour que le
climat dans notre pays soit le plus
apaisé que si il est extrêmement tendue
je parlais de l'américanisation des
esprits tout à l'heure si ça continue on
va se retrouver comme importante tout
comme à cannes au chat ça n'est pas la
france la france ne pas les usa la
france a un passé à des traditions qui
ne devons pas oublier
et encore une fois la couleur de la peau
ça nous est complètement légale et que
les médias responsables politiques
doivent faire attention à leur
expression ou faire attention à leur
attitude pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions livre le plus cossu en un
climat a fléchi
voilà ma non troppo général pendant
cette semaine donc ces contextes 1 qui
rajoute en tout cas à la main
voilà il s'inscrit dans un contexte un
contexte qui nous paraît à nous
responsables rassurent quant à
comparaître dangereux et tu proviens qui
a beaucoup de de multiples causes
notamment l'intérêt si de jeu macro et
de son gouvernement se sent le plus
possible est installée que ce débat
existe que l'on connaît toutes ces
tensions comme nout ariste indigéniste
antico loi et que sais-je etc
certains à l'instar du philosophe michel
onfray qui n'est pas franchement de
droite qui n'est pas forcément valeur
actuelle a néanmoins défendu le journal
non pas sur le fond mais sur la liberté
de la presse ils sont inquiètes est ce
que vous êtes d'accord
mais d'après cette liberté d'expression
elle est entière
à l'heure actuelle à sa totale liberté
d'expression mais moi aussi j'ai ma
liberté d'expression et je suis légitime
est libre d'exprimer mon opinion à
propos de ce décès dessin et à propos de
cet article dans ce cadre là on peut
dire que les poursuites judiciaires qui
seraient intentées contre valeurs
actuelles
on est évidemment un ne signifie pas
qu'elles sont pas sérieuses et sont plus
que pas sérieuse et songe tendent à le
sait la judiciarisation aussi notre
société et on va toujours voir le juge
attend des problèmes qui en fait sont
des problèmes politiques des problèmes
philosophiques des problèmes moraux qui
doivent être réglés notamment par les
poils et les responsables politiques
c'est une affaire qui devient politique
selon vous on voit la france organise
ces blocs la députée elle a toujours été
politique les tensions communautarisme
de notre pays sont un phénomène le
notamment politiques
attisées par l'incapacité des
gouvernements qui se sont succédé depuis
longtemps notamment des gouvernements
que actuelle c'est un problème politique
extrêmement important extrêmement
dangereux pour la paix sociale de notre
pays n'a pu même date explique notre
pays
si on se retrouve avec les émeutes et
des attitudes genre de portland ou
baltimore et 7 gr je serai extrême
énervant souchu quoi la france merci va
les rendre sans juste d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je vous en prie merci
beaucoup merci au revoir